carlos ou johnny ou salles nc deux
autres surnoms s'appellerait vladimir
ilitch sanchez
ici ils se trouvent sur l'aéroport
d'alger après la prise d'otage des
ministres de l'opep à vienne en décembre
carlos au début je l'avais pris pour un
mafioso italien a raconté un de ses
anciens complices
puis il m'est apparu comme une sorte de
james bond il serait originaire d'une
grande famille vénézuélienne parlerait
six langues vivraient dans l'opulence il
ferait payer très cher ses services de
mercenaires
un homme ou des hommes auxquels on
attribue de nombreuses actions en france
il apparaît pour la première fois en
juin 1975 à l'occasion d'une fusillade
rue toullier à paris à son domicile
il abat deux inspecteurs de la dst c'est
la première fois que l'on évoque
l'organisation de la lutte armée arabe
celle là même qui revendique le double
attentat de samedi soir le 15 août 1975
on évoque le nom de carlos dans
l'attentât du peuple saint germain qui
fait 2 morts et 33 blessés
des représailles contre l'état français
qui refusait de libérer les membres d'un
commando qui avait attaqué l'ambassade
de france à la haye
quelques mois plus tôt le 29 mars 1982
on voit sa main derrière l'explosion qui
tue cinq personnes et fait 27 blessés
dans le capitole
cet attentat ne sera jamais revendiqué
mais carlos avait auparavant adressé à
gaston defferre ministre de l'intérieur
un ultimatum authentifié exigent la
libération de mcb est née la coop et
bruno bréguet sur cette photo de membres
de son organisation le 27 mars le délai
de l'ultimatum est écoulé le 29 le
capitole et plastiquées
carlos revendique l'attentât contre la
maison de france à berlin qui fait un
mort et 23 blessés le 25 août 1983
s'agit-il de carlos terroristes
professionnels ou d'une organisation qui
utilisent ce nom la question se pose à
nouveau pour les deux attentats de
samedi